ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE.
WE CONSIDER THIS A PROVOCATION.
>> Bret: THE POISONING WITH
DAUGHTER, AND THE REACTION
TODAY.
DIPLOMATS KICKED OUT OF
GREAT BRITAIN.
MOMENTS AGO THE WHITE HOUSE
WEIGHING IN, SARAH SANDERS
RELEASING A STATEMENT.
"THIS LATEST ACTION BY RUSSIA
FITS INTO A PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR
IN WHICH RUSSIA DISREGARDS THE
INTERNATIONAL RULES BASED ORDER,
UNDERMINES THE SOVEREIGNTY AND
SECURITY OF COUNTRIES WORLDWIDE
AND ATTEMPTS TO SUBVERT OR
DISCREDIT WESTERN DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS AND PROCESSES.
THE UNITED STATES TO WORKING
TOGETHER WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
KIND OF ABHORRENT ATTACK DOES
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN."
SAYING THAT THEY SIDE WITH
GREAT BRITAIN ON THE
DETERMINATION RUSSIA WAS BEHIND
IT.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
STEVE HAYES, EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
"THE WEEKLY STANDARD."
MO ELLEITHEE, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE GEORGETOWN INSTITUTE OF
POLITICS.
STEVE HILTON, FORMER ADVISOR TO
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER DAVID
CAMERON AT HOST OF THE NEXT
REVELATION
REVOLUTION HERE ON
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
ACTION HERE, THEY HAD TO DO
SOMETHING.
THE DEADLINE THEY INSTALLED OR
LAID ON THE GROUND FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS LARGELY BEEN
DISREGARDED.
>> I AGREE WITH THE WORDS, THEY
ARE NICE WORDS BUT THE ACTIONS
ARE FRANKLY PATHETIC AND WILL
MAKE NO DIFFERENCE AT ALL.
IT'S IN LINE WITH THE WEST'S
HANDLING OF PUTIN FOR MANY YEARS
NOW.
GOING BACK NOT JUST IN PREVIOUS
BRITISH GOVERNMENTS WHERE YOU
HAD A SIMILAR POISONING
SITUATION WITH PRACTICALLY NO
RESPONSE UNDER THE PREVIOUS
LABOUR GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO WITH
THE U.S. ADMINISTRATION GOING
BACK TO BUSH AND OBAMA WHICH
HAVE ENCOURAGED PUTIN'S
ADVENTURISM BY DOING NOTHING.
WHATEVER HE DOES, WHETHER IT'S
WALKING INTO CRIMEA OR UKRAINE
OR WHATEVER.
THIS ACTION BY THE BRITISH IS
GOING THROUGH THE MOTIONS, AND
DIPLOMATIC GAME THAT YOU PLAY.
IT WILL MAKE NO IMPACT ON PUTIN
WHATSOEVER.
WE HAVE TO GET SERIOUS BECAUSE
DETERRING HIS ADVENTURISM IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT NOTCHES IN
THE CONTEXT OF RUSSIA BUT OTHER
DICTATORS AROUND THE WORLD LIKE
THE CHINESE WHO THINK THEY CAN
GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING.
BECAUSE THE WEST DOES NOT STAND
UP TO THEM.
>> Bret: JUST BEFORE THE SHOW
THE U.S. AMBASSADOR NIKKI HALEY
WAS A STRONG SPEECH AT THE U.N.
SECURITY COUNCIL, THIS ABOUT
RUSSIA AGGRESSION.
>> THE RUSSIANS COMPLAINED
RECENTLY THAT WE CRITICIZE THEM
TOO MUCH.
IF THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT STOPS
USING CHEMICAL WEAPONS TO
ASSASSINATE ITS ENEMIES AND IF
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT STOPPED
HELPING ITS SYRIAN ALLIES TO USE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS TO KILL SYRIAN
CHILDREN AND HAVE RUSSIA
COOPERATED WITH THE ORGANIZATION
FOR THE PROHIBITION OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS BY TURNING OVER ALL
INFORMATION RELATED TO THIS
NERVE AGENT, WE WOULD STOP
TALKING ABOUT THEM.
>> Bret: SHE GOES ON TO SAY
THE CREDIBILITY OF THIS COUNCIL,
THE U.N. SECURITY COUNCIL, WILL
NOT SURVIVE IF WE FAIL TO HOLD
RUSSIA ACCOUNTABLE.
IS THAT THE TALKING AT LEAST
CHANGING FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT WE ARE HEARING, I THOUGHT
IT WAS A STRONG SPEECH BY
AMBASSADOR HALEY.
I THOUGHT HER TRYING TO HOLD THE
SECURITY COUNCIL ACCOUNTABLE IN
ITS EFFORTS TO HOLD RUSSIA
ACCOUNTABLE WAS A SMART MOVE.
APPLY HER WORDS TO HER BOSS, TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHO DOES NOT HAVE VERY MUCH
CREDIBILITY RIGHT NOW IN HOLDING
RUSSIA ACCOUNTABLE.
YES WE NEED A DIPLOMATIC EFFORT.
WE NEED TO ENGAGE THE
UNITED NATIONS AND THE SECURITY
COUNCIL BUT IT ALL RINGS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
CONTINUES HIS FLIRTATION WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND CONTINUES TO
LET HIM OFF THE HOOK.
STATEMENTS BY THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY AND THE U.N.
AMBASSADOR, NO MATTER HOW STRONG
THEY ARE, DO NOT CARRY THE SAME
WEIGHT AS STATEMENTS BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHO HAS BEEN SILENT.
>> Bret: OKAY, THIS IS WHAT
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS TO THAT.
THIS IS SARAH SANDERS.
FROM A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
OH, WE DON'T HAVE THIS.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT SHE SAYS.
"THE ACTIONS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, THAT HE'S BEEN
EXTREMELY TOUGH ON RUSSIA,
HELPED PUSH THROUGH $700 BILLION
TO REBUILD THE MILITARY," GOES
OUT TO SAY EXPORTING ENERGY TO
EASTERN EUROPE, RUSSIA IS NOT
EXCITED ABOUT IT.
KEEPS THE IN PLACE.
WE HAVE DANIELLE, SHE WAS
ON "MEET THE PRESS" ABOUT THE
SANCTIONS REGIME AND HOW THIS IS
ADMINISTRATION IS HANDLING IT.
SHE'S NOT A SUPPORTER IN THE
CAMPAIGN OF DONALD TRUMP.
SHE WAS NEVER TRUMP IN THE
CAMPAIGN BUT HERE'S WHAT SHE
SAID.
>> MISSILE SANCTIONS, NUCLEAR
SANCTIONS, I'VE NEVER SEEN AN
ADMINISTRATION MOVE SO FAST AS
THEY DID.
THIS IS A PROCESS.
I DON'T WANT TO DEFEND THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHERE THEY DON'T
DESERVE IT BUT IN THIS CASE THEY
HAVE DONE A LOT.
>> Bret: IN OTHER WORDS,
ACTIONS, ARE THEY DOING A LOT?
>> IN CERTAIN RESPECTS, THEY
HAVE DONE A LOT.
THEY COULD BE DOING MORE.
THEY'VE BEEN ARMING THE
UKRAINIANS.
THE EVENT TAKING CERTAIN STEPS
TO SEND CERTAIN MESSAGES BUT I
AGREE WITH MO.
THIS REQUIRES A PRESIDENTIAL
LEVEL STATEMENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS TRIED NOT
TO GET AHEAD OF WHERE THE BRITS
WERE.
THEY WANTED OUR STATEMENTS TO
MATCH AS THE BRITS GOT MORE
AGGRESSIVE, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS GOTTEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE BUT THERE'S NOTHING
THAT TAKES THE PLACE OF A
PRESIDENTIAL STATEMENT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT WHEN
DONALD TRUMP IS UNHAPPY ABOUT
SOMETHING, HE'S VERY CLEAR ABOUT
WHO HE IS NOT HAPPY WITH NY.
WE COULD SEE HIM I WOULD SAY BE
TOUGH ON THIS AND ALSO ADD IN A
STATEMENT ABOUT CONTINUED RUSSIA
CYBER ACTIVITIES AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES AND ITS CITIZENS
AROUND THE WORLD.
A WARNING NOT TO ATTACK U.S.
BACKED REBELS, FORCES IN SYRIA.
THERE ARE MANY WAYS IN WHICH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
CAN SEND A CLEAR AND UNAMBIGUOUS
MESSAGE THAT HE HASN'T WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
CAN BE DONE IS HIT PUTIN AND
RUSSIA WHERE IT HURTS, THAT IS
IN THE FIELD OF ENERGY.
IT IS CORRECT TO SAY SOME
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE ON THAT
BUT I THINK ACTUALLY THIS
ADMINISTRATION COULD GO MUCH,
MUCH FURTHER IN HELPING THE
EUROPEANS GET RID OF THEIR
DEPENDENCE ON RUSSIAN ENERGY.
THAT ALSO HELPS AMERICAN JOBS
AND INDUSTRIES HERE.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO SEE WHO IS
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS,
LOOK AT ANGELA MERKEL.
SHE IS LITERALLY ABOUT TO GO
AHEAD WITH THE PIPELINE THAT
BUYS ALL THE GAS PUTIN WANTS TO
SELL.
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT
MAKES PUTIN THINK IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT HE DOES, ALL THESE
WORDS.
IN THE END, HE'S GOING TO BE
FINE BECAUSE THE EUROPEANS ARE
SO DEPENDENT ON HIM FOR ENERGY.
>> Bret: FOR ALL THE
AGGRESSION RUSSIA HAS IN ALL THE
BRAVADO PUTIN BRINGS TO
EVERYTHING HE TALKS ABOUT, HE'S
NOT HOLDING A LOT OF GREAT CARDS
AS FAR AS HIS OWN ECONOMY.
AND RUSSIA'S STANCE IN ECONOMIC